[Musique]
dans la jungle et les mangroves
luxuriante au bord de l'océan pacifique
des formes étranges des épaves qui ne
ressemble pas à celle de bateaux
traditionnels
ce sont les traces d'une guerre sans
merci que mène la marine colombienne
c'est un sous-marin qu'on a saisi il ya
quelques temps
marine nationale colombienne contre
flotte navale des trafiquants de drogue
voici l'incroyable bataille
contre les sous marins de marquer
qu'ils étaient sous les ordres mon
colonel
bien on va s'attaquer à la chaîne du
narcotrafic et nous allons mener une
opération pour lutter contre ce fléau
mondial
ce jour-là nous embarquons avec cette
unité d'infanterie de marine direction
le dédale de rivières et de mangrove en
bord d'océan dans le sud de la colombie
le bateau avance le plus silencieusement
possible
avancer lentement les deux mitrailleuses
latéral surveillez bien les berges
l'officier cherche le moindre signe qui
le mettrait sur la piste des trafiquants
l'acquéreur est la fia est ici cette
partie de la colombie est propice à la
culture de la cocaïne ce sont des lieux
inhospitaliers
recul est difficile d'accès et ça permet
aussi aux trafiquants de cacher des
laboratoires et des bases dans ses
mangroves avant d'exporter leur
cargaison
quand les militaires repères quelque
chose il débarque et s'enfoncent dans la
jungle pour eux le danger est réel face
aux cartels qui défendront chèrement
leur peau ce jour là ses soldats tombent
sur cette base clandestine que les
narcotrafiquants semble avoir évacué à
leur approche c'est un mini chantiers
navals ce sous-marin est pratiquement
achevée au sol les matériaux utilisés
fibre de verre pour la coque peinture
spéciale moteurs de bateaux des
équipements qui peuvent être onéreux
mais sont en vente libre
construire ces sous-marins coûtent selon
les modèles jusqu'à six cent mille euros
pièce mais le kilo de cocaïne et revendu
près de 30000 euros aux états unis et
ses sous marins ont une capacité de 2 ou
3 tonnes donc on parle de cargaison dont
la valeur atteint près de 80 millions
d'euros la marge est considérable pour
les trafiquants
quand ils ne sont pas repérés à terre
les narcotrafiquants mettent leurs
sous-marins à l'eau et s'élance sur des
milliers de kilomètres
direction l'amérique centrale et le
mexique où les cartels feront ensuite
passer la drogue aux états unis
les marines colombiennes et américaines
coopèrent pour les intercepter comme ici
avec ce spectaculaire abordage en haute
mer
sur la base navale de tout mac os les
militaires exhibent leurs prises de
guerre ces engins ont commencé à
apparaître il ya vingt ans les cartels
ont recruté des ingénieurs mercenaires
probablement russe pour apprendre à les
construire certains comme celui ci sont
de vrais sous marin qui s'immerge
complètement à une dizaine de mètres de
profondeur avec un équipage de trois à
cinq hommes
le premier compartiment avant c'est là
où il stocke la cargaison de drogue
derrière c'est le compartiment de
pilotage avec l'équipage
le dernier compartiment c la partie
moteur et des réserves de carburant
mais la plupart sont des semi
submersible tout plat ils naviguent au
ras des flots
la plupart du temps ils naviguent à vue
ils sont en position debout la main sur
le gouvernail et la tête par l'ouverture
quotidiennement les garde-côtes
s'entraîne à stopper non seulement les
sous marins mais aussi les go fast ces
hors-bord rapide qui tente d'exporter la
drogue
la marine estime qu'au total elle
intercepte un peu plus de la moitié des
1200 tonnes de cocaïne produites chaque
année en colombie